do you think the builders of Stonehenge
played music builder builder one man one
man built stone command so again it goes
against this new theory of thousands of
people and all that that's being thrown
out there by all due respect National
Geographic
you know big settlements thousands of
houses and all that they say oh look we
found the outline of a house the steps
go down this is where they had their
little fire one man very strong yes if
you could ask the builders of Stonehenge
the Builder yeah the Builder of
Stonehenge the scene was his name by the
way
Duncan Duncan yeah they didn't have last
names in just so Duncan the Builder of
Duncan's already calling calling Danka
if you could ask him yet one question
yes what what would it be
I say hey doing and nothing about the
construction I know what you did if
you'd like me to play this game or will
I've done it before
Duncan how did you build Stonehenge well
I didn't actually build it well you're
not talking I'm saying this is little
theoretical now you would say hundreds
of you well I've got myself a drill and
I built it you know I'm curious have you
read any books on Stonehenge I read that
book Catcher in the Rye would that count